[Music]
humanity has always been propelled by a
dramatic innovation you know in in the
20s and 30s we knew that we would run
out of food by the 70s we invented a
nitrogen phosphorus potassium based
fertilizer and that created the Green
Revolution that now can feed everybody
on the planet these are always solutions
that create like that are driven by an
unbelievable ecosystem an unbelievable
need and the unending and unyielding
spirit of innovation that defines
humanity right so those things combined
are what make it so exciting so like you
know so if we look at the cost of
Alzheimer's if we look at the cost of
and this isn't all neurological
disorders this is just Alzheimer's if we
look at those costs direct and indirect
we're spending as much taking care of
people with Alzheimer's every year as an
Iraq war so the the magnitude of these
numbers is is astronomical
these numbers are devastating and it and
we could all be pretty morose about it
the reality is that I've never felt more
optimistic to be alive I've never felt
better about the environment that we're
in in terms of solving problems being
able to identify them being able to
direct resources to them something that
I found out that blew my mind was that
this year for the first time in three
years and for the first time in in since
the Spanish flu we'll have three years
in a row of decreasing longevity in the
United States we will live less long
three years in a row less long than ever
and everybody else believes that we're
living longer and longer and longer it's
it's it's it's driven primarily by two
things and primarily Alzheimer's is the
number one driver in this and the
secondary driver unfortunately is is
drug overdoses and suicides it's it's
it's related to the opioid epidemic
we're actually developing products for
both of those primary problems for both
of those decreases in longevity so we're
working on a suite of non opioid pain
alternatives but our lead compound is a
vaccine for Alzheimer's and what that
does is it means that we can we can
really turn on the body's immune system
and ill it and enable it to fight toxic
proteins that it's generating itself and
what
special about that to me is that the
largest gains back to this longevity
idea the largest gains in human
longevity ever are debatably attributed
to vaccine technology now some people
you can also the sanitation was very
important the antibiotic revolution was
very important but vaccine technologies
currently over 6.2 billion people in the
world have been vaccinated right now
these are the most widely distributed
medications and solutions that have ever
been brought to mankind and the
consequence was that we really
dramatically improved our quality of
life and our longevity we gave people
better healthier longer lives and now
the big problem with vaccines is that
you could never use them against non
external targets so they worked great
with viruses whether it was Ebola or
Zika polio smallpox you know we actually
can solve those problems pretty fast for
the external targets but now what's
killing us more than everything external
are actually for the first time this
year the bark rust and internal things
are killing us more so the agents of
chronic illness so it's no longer
fighting bacteria and viruses and these
other external causes of death or causes
of suffering or causes of disease
instead it's internal ones it's things
that are causing atherosclerosis and
heart disease and stroke things that are
causing cancers things that are causing
diabetes Alzheimer's Parkinson's all of
these different chronic illnesses now
why don't we vaccinate against chronic
illness well the idea is that you be
fundamentally targeting something that's
in your own body right like you'd be
targeting something your body was making
and so what's what does that sound like
it sounds like an autoimmune disease it
sounds like if you made your body do
that it could trigger an autoimmune
disease and it turns out that that's one
of the big challenges in making vaccines
against things your body generates and
they call that the self barrier or
breaking self tolerance or all of these
like different things that describe this
phenomena but the bottom line is the
body does not like to attack itself and
it's trying not to and for millions of
years our immune systems have evolved so
that we don't do exactly that
now what's awesome is that our
technology platform has been able to do
it and do it safely and we've been able
to do it in in a lot of applications so
to me this is our Sputnik moment right
this is my generations opportunity to
say for the first time the ecosystem the
pieces the motivation the goals are
there we're aligning around this and we
have an absolute opportunity to make a
dramatic impact and it'll be that
village it'll be that ecosystem that
ultimately achieves the goal you know
when we put people on the moon and I
tell my team this all the time no one
person put someone on the moon there
were over a thousand different companies
that were all involved full-time going a
thousand miles an hour there were
companies that were making the screens
there were companies making the knobs
there were companies making the wiring
systems the rocket engines there were
companies making the external heat
deflectors these are so many little
details and without all of them it
doesn't work so when we go after things
that are that are really big goals and
when we go after huge problems it's that
village it's that ecosystem that solves
it and and and I really have a firm
belief that this is like the greatest
time that we could possibly be alive and
and solving these problems it are some
of the greatest problems facing mankind
but they're also you know we've never
been we've never had a better chance of
solving them you know so I feel like
it's a really great time
[Music]